with cancer
the makeshift tent you can see was made
by his son to provide cover for David as
he lays shivering on the rain-swept
concrete floor where he'd Fallen he had
fractured ribs and a fractured pelvis
and he was forced to wait 15 hours for
an ambulance
this is the state of the NHS in Tory
Britain and it is an absolute disgrace
we have
we have the highest NHS waiting lists in
history people unable to see their GP
heart attack and stroke victims left
waiting longer than an hour for an
ambulance when every second counts the
Tories will try to blame the pandemic
but we had a hundred thousand nhf staff
vacancies before the pandemic NHS
waiting lists were already at a record
four and a half million before the
pandemic the number of cancer patients
not getting Care on time Rose in every
single year since the Tories came to
power before the pandemic so it's clear
the longer the conservatives are in
power the longer patients will wait
and you know
and you know the tourists might run from
their record but we're proud of ours
proud of 89 000 more nurses 44 000 more
doctors faster cancer treatment the
lowest waiting times on record and the
highest patient satisfaction in history
that's the difference a labor government
makes
but the challenge today is even greater
than it was in 1997. the very principle
of an NHS publicly funded free at the
point of use is now under attack
conservatives who spent the last 12
years running down the NHS are now using
their failures to claim for the NHS is
beyond repair
lots of you know that I went through
kidney cancer last year and when I
received that cancer diagnosis there
were so many things I had to worry about
but the one thing I didn't have to worry
about was the bill so to those who argue
that we should abandon a publicly funded
NHS free at the point of use I say Over
My Dead Body
the conference I'm a labor modernizer I
make no apology for it because if we
don't modernize and change the NHS it
will become unsustainable so here's what
we'll do to make the NHS fit for the
future without a Workforce plan the
conservatives have no plan for the NHS
everything else they announce is a
sticking plaster that fails to address
the root cause of the NHS crisis
politics is about choices labor believes
the country needs doctors and nurses
more than the richest needs a tax cut so
thanks to Rachel Reeves we'll double the
number of medical training places and
create an extra 10 000 nursing and
Midwifery clinical placements every year
more doctors more nurses lower waiting
times higher standards for patients
that's the labor pledge at the next
general election
and of course
alongside investment will come the
change and modernization that the public
are crying out for voters won't accept
pouring more money into a 20th century
Healthcare that isn't fit for the future
we don't Focus nearly enough on
prevention early intervention and Care
in the community because people can't
see a GP they end up in a e which is
worse for them and more expensive for
the taxpayer because people can't get
the mental health support they need they
reach a crisis point which is worse for
them and more expensive for the taxpayer
because people can't get the social care
they need they're left stuck in hospital
which is worse for them and more
expensive for the taxpayer so the next
Labor government will agree a 10-year
plan with the NHS to shift the focus of
Health Care out of the hospital and into
the community
and our plan our plan to recruit more
doctors will deliver better access to
GPS and ease pressure on a E's our plan
to recruit eight and a half thousand
mental health workers will provide
faster treatment support in schools and
ease pressure on hospitals and our
commitment to deliver better pay terms
and conditions for care workers will
reduce the 400 000 delayed discharges
every month provide better quality care
for older and disabled people and will
be the first steps on the road to a
national care service
thank you
and you know there are so many people in
hospital who wouldn't need to be there
if we could provide quality Care at home
District nursing will be at the heart of
Labor's plan the conservatives have cut
four in ten District nurse posts labor
will double the number of District
nurses qualifying every year
and you know
for kids from working class backgrounds
like mine lifig chance life chances and
even life expectancy can be determined
from the moment we are born Health
visitors have such an important role to
play in helping mums and dads that
they're managing dangerously High case
loads so we will train 5 000 Health
visitors to tackle the shortage and give
every child the best Healthy Start in
life
and you know
our 10-year plan for the NHS will be the
antidote to the Tory miserableism about
the NHS and its future I want Britain
leading the revolution in Medical
Science and Technology it offers a world
of possibility for the NHS to transform
patient care technology can diagnose
patients more accurately than the human
eye virtual Wards allow patients to
receive hospital care at home but the
biggest prize of all is the advance in
genomics and the data Revolution that
will allow us to transform our model of
care from one that diagnoses and treats
illness to one that can predict and
prevent it this will be at the heart of
Labor's 10-year plan for Change and
modernization and so will higher
standards for patients
as Labor's Secretary of State for Health
and Social care I'll be the shop steward
for patients giving patients a voice as
well as choice because patients deserve
better than a two-week wait to see a GP
I have higher standards for patients
when we were in government labor
guaranteed appointments within two days
so labor will give all the patients the
ability to book online the opportunity
to self-refer to specialist Services
were appropriate and a wider range of
choice so that we can choose whether we
want to see someone face to face or on
the phone or via video link the days of
waiting on the phone at 8am to book an
appointment with your GP will be over
and we will bring back the family doctor
foreign
the NHS isn't just Labor's greatest
achievement it's Britain's greatest
achievement and the values that underpin
the NHS a publicly funded Public Service
free at the point of views aren't just
Labor's values they're Britain's values
too and our party has always understood
that the NHS needs to change to adapt to
Modern challenges so now it falls to our
generation no more overflowing a E's and
waiting weeks to see a doctor no more
patients dying before they can get the
treatment they need no more staff in
tears leaving the NHS broken and
exhausted no more cancer patients left
under makeshift shelters in their
Gardens waiting 15 years for an
ambulance no more of that conference
instead will deliver a labor government
empowering patients cherishing staff
shifting to prevention caring in the
community giving real choices tackling
inequalities building a national care
service and an NHS fit for the future
let's send a message to Britain
conference the Cavalry is coming with
labor so let's go out there and win for
labor win for the NHS and win for
Britain thank you conference
thank you
foreign
we've got a lot to get through so I want
to progress some of the business
starting with the references back which
come from socialist Health Association
labor International CLP Beverly and
holdness CLP Sutton and team CLP of
course and I lived in West Norris CLP
and can I also ask that the
um